kommen wir nun zu einem weiteren thema
heute abend bei das von andrej melik was
ernst mitgebracht hat es geht um öl und
gas und ob wir die importe
stoppen soll
ja das ist nach wie vor die schärfste
waffe die deutschen aber auch die die eu
hat in der hand gegenüber herrn putin
wir oder die deutschen und die europäer
zahlen pro tag
in die kriegskasse von hand mutigen
knapp eine milliarde euro und wenn man
bedenkt dass das das haushalt das
militärische haushalte russlands knapp
60 milliarden euro pro jahr beträgt dann
kann man sich ausrechnen dass das in
zwei monaten
hatten russland wieder einen neuen
mieter um diesen krieg fortzusetzen noch
weitere sechs jahre innerhalb eines
jahres in der man für die gas
lieferungen nach russland zahlt und
deswegen glauben wir schon das dass die
bundesregierung die immer wieder jetzt
eine ablehnende haltung eingenommen hat
dass diese position schnellstens
geändert werden muss denn wenn wir schon
mit sanktionen mit diesen mechanismen
agieren dann glaube ich schon es wäre
eine sünde die diese größte waffe die
man hat das ist eine keule das ist es
wichtig dass das las womit man
vielleicht auch diesen krieg beenden
kann und zwar sehr schnell dass man
diese keule nicht benutzt gegenüber
herrn putin und deswegen wollen wir auch
an die bundesregierung appellieren an
die deutschen und die deutschen
unterstützen übrigens über die hälfte
der deutschen glaubt umfragen würden
diesen schritt befürworten aber die
regierung stellt sich weil man eben sich
sorgen gemacht
um den sozialen zusammenhalt usw das
kann man verstehen als so trainer aber
wenn man die bilder sieht das was jetzt
bei uns los ist eine hülle lust ein
inferno auf erden und das muss man auch
doch im verhältnis sehen das was heute
morgen unternommen werden könnte und
sollte hier in deutschland das könnte
tausende menschenleben retten in der
ukraine ganz konkret und das ist auch
nach wie vor unsere bitte an die
bundesregierung an die menschen hier in
diesem schönen land zu helfen und diese
meinung zu ändern so schnell wie möglich
ich habe es ja mal ganz wichtigen punkt
gemacht weil sie von einem scharfen
schwert gesprochen haben und ich glaube
wir können schon feststellen dass die
westliche welt extrem eng zusammensteht
dass putin das gegenteil von dem
erreicht hat was er eigentlich wollte
den westen zu dividieren nein das
gegenteil ist passiert und ich glaube
dass der krieg den putin der angezettelt
hat ohnehin teuer wird so oder so für
den westen sei es durch waffenlieferung
sei es durch ein militärisches
eingreifen oder sei es eben dadurch dass
man sagt okay wir stoppen mit dem
übermorgen tage oder anfang nächster
woche alle importe die wir haben in
sachen gas und öl das wird natürlich
vorübergehend zu einem dramatischen
weiteren anstieg von gas- und ölpreisen
führen das ist richtig aber die frage
ist aber welche kosten sind da zu
schultern und welche kosten wären zu
schultern wenn dieser krieg noch lange
lange weitergeht und die russischen
armee möglicherweise bis an die
polnische grenze voran kommen oder
vielleicht sogar darüber hinaus dass wir
am kostenberg man sich gar nicht
vorstellen und von daher ist glaubt man
sich da ein punkt zu sagen lager werk
sofort heime import einhaken gerne am
see hynix hat er bislang haben die
sanktionen ja noch nicht gezeigt dass
sie dabei helfen den krieg aufzuhalten
und man hat natürlich die sanktion als
abschreckungs mechanismus aber wenn wir
jetzt schon jede abschrankung in einem
ball machen in dieses schwert und
draufhauen haben wir kaum noch
abschreckung also irgendwie sind wir
alle unsere mittel erst mal weg also
woran sehen wir denn bislang dass
vladimir putin auf die sanktion so
reagiert dass er den krieg beenden wird
er hat diese sanktionen die schon heute
eingeführt wurden einkalkuliert ja der
wusste ganz genau was auf ihn zukommen
könnte
das war in seiner kalkulation ganz
bestimmt zwölf zum beispiel war
womöglich nicht dabei dass beim swift
müsste man dann nachlegen und all die
banken ausschließen nicht nur die sieben
die jetzt betroffenen sind das heißt
auch die größte die sberbank die
gazprombank über diese zahlungen für
gaslieferungen
erfolgen all die anderen banken das
würde wirklich eine enorme wirkung
erzeugen und das zweite
nämlich dieses embargo man könnte auch
mit seinem oratorium versuchen ein monat
wird kein gas kein öl keine kohle wird
gekauft und dann schauen das heißt auch
dass man man der besten hat so viele
möglichkeiten in der hand und die werden
kaum genutzt man wartet ab man man man
hat angst dass das vielleicht eine
gegenreaktion
sie kostet geld ja wir sehen ja aber
schon auch das was man an berichten aus
russland hört sieht bilder die man sieht
dass die sanktionen durchaus wirkung
zeigen irgendwann merkte sind leer es
gibt der schlange an automaten automaten
spucken nur noch einen ganz ganz kleinen
teil maximal 8000 rubel aus also 68 euro
umgerechnet die man abheben kann täglich
also da wird schon massiv rationalisiert
bei putin weiß die sanktionen treffen
ihn und sein land extrem hart wir hören
dass möglicherweise weil die flugzeuge
nicht mehr gewartet werden die flugzeug
linien wie beispielsweise aeroflot
vielleicht noch zwei vielleicht noch
drei wochen überhaupt fliegen können
dann müssten die am boden bleiben weil
sie nicht mehr gewartet werden bzw und
auch ersatzteilen also ein land eine
hoffnung was eigentlich in den
kompletten absturz gerät wir hören von
ökonomen die sagen sie rechne mit einem
absturz der wirtschaftsleistung um 35
prozent in russland das sind dramatische
zahlen klar und dann ist die frage
begehrt eine bevölkerung auf ganz klar
ist für putin wird es wenn das sich
alles durch setzt zumindest im land
extrem ungemütlich paul ich für dich an
dieser stelle gerne reinhold keiner ist
so nah wie du gerade in kiew direkt vor
ort was sagst du kriegst unsere
diskussionen mit sollten wir sollten in
deutschland die öl- und gasimporte
stoppen wie ist die stimmung vor ort
wird es ein aufbegehren auch in russland
gegen putin irgendwann geben
deutschland sollte dieses embargo sofort
verhängt aus meiner sicht wir können es
mit unseren werten nicht vereinbaren mit
unseren
mit unserer moral die wir gerne als
deutsche vor uns hertragen mit dem wir
auf die welt blicken wie wir dinge
analysieren wie wir dinge kritisieren
jetzt ist die stunde gekommen jetzt
müssen uns beweisen in einem moment wo
zivilisten mit raketen ermordet werden
wo ganze städte in schutt und asche
gelegt werden mario pohl aktiv wie
kinder frauen angegriffen werden wie
nichts mehr wirklich gar nichts mehr
heilig ist heute stand ich vor einer
fast komplett zerstörten kirche da kann
es doch nicht unser ernst sein dass wir
jetzt sagen aus sorge vor einer
wirtschaftlichen verlust aus sorge dafür
dass dann ist probleme gibt
dass wir das nicht tun das ist für mich
völlig unverständlich und ich kann nur
hoffen dass es genauso wie bei swift
sein wird denn da hat sich der
bundeskanzler auch zunächst gesperrt
auch in den wochen vorher dieses ist
immer neuen swift das geht ja gar nicht
so kompliziert doch es geht das sehen
wir ja und das andere geht natürlich
auch und nur diese sprache versteht
wladimir putin und diese sprache wenn es
schon keine flugverbotszone gibt wenn
wir hier schon nicht
eingreifen können dann doch zumindest
dass die schärfsten sanktionen die die
welt jemals gesehen hat und eine ganz
klare sprache es geht keine minute mehr
dass dieser krieg weitergeht aber wie
viel bringen uns die sanktion wenn china
nicht mitziehen das ist ja schon die
gefahr gerade da der china und russland
immer immer enger zusammen werden und
dann wir nicht wirklich agieren können
das sollte uns erstmal egal sein das
können wir nicht beeinflussen natürlich
ist es richtig dass china wichtig ist
das ist alles richtig auf der anderen
seite zeigt sich dass die ukraine gerade
die freiheit des westens verteidigt denn
wenn die ukraine sich sofort ergeben
hätten nach zwei oder drei tagen wenn
dieses militär nicht so stehen würde
wenn die moral nicht so groß wäre hier
im ganzen land dann wäre das ja nur der
anfang denn hätte russland gesehen ach
wir können schnell einmarschieren und
wir übernehmen mein land und wer ist als
nächstes dran das gleiche in china
gedacht und gesagt ja dann versuchen wir
doch mal in taiwan da wird sicherlich
auch nichts passiert also die ukraine
jeder einzelne mensch der hier gerade an
der front steht verteidigt unsere
freiheit unsere ganz persönliche
freiheit und auch unsere ganz
persönliche sicherheit das ist ganz
wichtig zu sagen und was die sanktionen
angeht wir können natürlich versuchen
auch china einfluss zu nehmen das ist
auch wichtig aber am ende stehen wir für
unsere eigene regierung für unsere
eigenen kurs und unabhängig davon was
china macht sollten wir als deutsche
klar blicken und klar sehen und klar
schauen und wenn man sieht dass hier
hinter mir in kiew demnächst die raketen
rein hageln können wie in mario pohl wie
attraktiv wie in ihre pin wo ich war
dann müssen wir doch sagen wie können
wir noch einen einzigen tag russisches
öl und gas importieren
ich glaube man muss sagen es geht nur
eins aber wir brauchen dann kann ich
beides verweigern kann nicht verweigern
harte sanktionen und man kann nicht
verweigern wir liefern waffen also es
gibt mindestens eins muss man aufgeben
wenn ich das einfach mal sagen dass paul
auch vollkommen richtig die
bundesregierung kann ich sagen wir
wollen das eigentlich und das andere
auch nicht zählt nicht ja wir brauchen
am ende ein embargo wir brauchen auch
vor allem ein öl-embargo weiter das
substitut für uns oder die alternative
für uns etwas einfacher ist wir brauchen
es aber europäische und amerikanische
und wir brauchen es gemeinsam mit den
amerikanern und den europäern weil herr
botschafter sie haben eben gerade auch
die zahlen genannt das ist das scharfe
schwert deutschland alleine ist viel
aber das scharfe schwert ist wenn wir es
als amerikaner
und als europäer gemeinsam machen und
die muss auch sagen da fand ich es auch
zu wenig was ich gehört habe von der
reise von robert habeck was er am ende
dort auch aus amerika mitgebracht hatte
ich finde es gut dass heute ja auch
us-außenminister blinken das ganze thema
in der europäischen union mit den
ministern und mit dem mit der kommission
diskutiert hat von daher ist es wir sind
auf diesem weg und ich kann die deutsche
bundesregierung nur ermutigen diesen weg
weiter zu pushen wir müssen diesen weg
gehen aber wirklich stark im markt im
weltmarkt sind wir wenn wir als westen
gemeinsam als europäer und als
amerikaner gemeinsam agieren